[Music]
here we will showcase the 15 biggest
dragons from movies and tv shows
we will have both the live action and
animated dragons in this list
just the awesome ones though and to be
fair we will put them in accordance to
length so let's get to it
number 15 the great protector the
smallest on this list is still a huge
beast the great protector was a dragon
scene in the movie shang chi and the
legend of the ten rings it is a
benevolent guardian of the people living
in a pocket dimension called tarlow its
enemy is the dweller in darkness and its
soul eaters the dragon although cannot
breed fire can bestow gifts upon people
the length of this dragon was around 30
meters or 100 feet long
number 14 drogon drogon was one of the
three dragons that was seen in game of
thrones and was the largest of his
siblings this dragon was black in color
and with reddish tints in his scales and
wings his scales were very sharp with
spikes on his back and horns on the
sides of his head drogon in the last
season of game of thrones grew to be 30
to 36 meters or 100 to 120 feet long
number 13 the bull dragon seen in the
movie reign of fire he is the alpha male
and a leader of his race as well as the
sole surviving male while all the other
dragons left are females the bull dragon
has a short snout long head horns small
cheek horns and being the oldest and
presumably the last remaining male in
existence he had grown considerably
large up to 46 meters or 150 feet long
number 12 dragon storm from the
transformers movie the last knight
dragonstorm is a beastly tree-headed
dragon a mighty combined form of the
legendary 12th knights of eocon who are
in opposition to a genocidal transformer
called quintessa this robotic dragon
dwarfs every other transformer except
for the driller dragon storm is
estimated to be around 200 feet or 60
meters long
number 11 veigar this dragon was one of
the three dragons of aegon the conqueror
ridden by one of his sister-wise vicenia
vega a gigantic yellowish dragon will be
seen in house of the dragon and by that
time she would have been over 175 years
of age we have done a size estimate for
this dragon and found out that she would
be between 250 to 300 feet long with a
skull that is around 15 to 26 feet
number 10 the screaming death seen in
the animated series of how to train your
dragon the screaming death is a heavily
mutated albino whispering death it is
white in color has very large eyes that
are red in color a longer and a more
massive body and a larger tail than the
average whispering death its head alone
is around 50 feet long and with its long
tail it comes to be around 365 feet or
111 meters
number nine the red death seen in the
very first movie how to train your
dragon the red death was the main
antagonist of that movie and drove the
divide and hatred between the dragons
and humans its head is heavily armed
with a nasal horn coral shaped thrill
and jaws that are lined with very sharp
and needle-like teeth it has three pairs
of eyes that gives it no
blind spot whatsoever it also has
massive wings it is also 400 feet or 120
meters long
number eight smoke the villain of the
hobbit smart was the very last great
dragon although he was little compared
to his ancestors he was still very
dreadful and responsible for the death
and the exile of the dwarves from erebor
the lonely mountain
smog is described as a serpentine dragon
and from some reliable accounts as being
130 meters or 427 feet long which is
very apt as he does tower over buildings
in lake town
number seven the bewilder bees
adult bewildered bees are very
incredibly massive four-legged dragons
with a pair of gigantic tusks protruding
from the sides of their heads just like
elephants they have a flat face a
humanoid flat face and two hypnotizing
eyes a large flaring crown of spikes fan
out from the back of the head and they
also have wings but were adapted to
swimming instead of flying and they can
breathe ice instead of fire and are over
520 feet or 159 meters long
number six the celestial dragon
this is a dragon that appeared in the
2007 korean fantasy film called dragon
walls in its original appearance the
great serpent is described as a brown to
grey blue scale cobra like beast but
after consuming the yuju a mystical
transformational soul energy it became a
celestial eastern dragon which is over
200 meters or 650 feet long and could
fly without wings
number 5 the monster verse ghidorah
seen in godzilla king of the monsters as
a rival apex predator to godzilla
himself ghidorah was discovered by
monarch dorman inside the antarctic ice
it was a three-headed dragon with a
golden body two massive wings and two
long and bob tails
although it is 521 feet tall
its length however with the tail could
put it between 900 to 1000 feet or 300
to 330 meters long
number four yamato no orochi
in the movie the three treasures orochi
looks like a giant snake with eight
heads
also with eight small tales
in orochi another movie the eighth
header dragon is now a more draconic
appearance with a bulky body and stubby
legs it is red with multiple yellow
horns on its head and small spikes
sticking out from the tail but it was
smaller than the first movie so in the
first movie it was over 300 meters long
or around 1000 feet
number three the world gobbler the world
gobbler is the main antagonist of the
2008 french german luxembourgish
computer animated film called dragon
hunters aside from the wings which were
very big the world gobbler resembles a
tyrannosaurus rex a skeleton the spikes
on the back also resemble the back
plates of the stegosaurus this monstrous
titan was over one thousand feet long
from the tip of the skull to the tail
number 2 void ghidorah seen in the
animated movie godzilla the planet eater
it is seen as a monstrous entity that
takes the form of a golden three-headed
dragon and inhabits the void between
dimensions guidora here uses
supergravity to consume countless worlds
throughout the thousands of years of his
existence this kaiju dragon is over 20
kilometers long or over 65 000 feet
and number one shenron this is a magical
dragon that emerges when one collects
all seven dragon balls and speaks a chan
or a specific phrase this dragon is
serpentine and resembles the chinese or
eastern dragons
shenron has been seen in multiple animes
manga even a live action film and games
from being a few hundred meters long to
being the size of the universe itself he
is the biggest
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video
and with that we come to the end of it
so do hit that like button for support
and subscribe as well but most of all
smash that bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam